c'est vrai que laeticia est en pleine
campagne de promo pour le nouvel album
avec le rhône en terre fait qui s'est
tournée je crois en 2007 2016 2016 et
letizia était en pleine hautmont là on
l'a vu absolument partout afin que à
part qui nous touchent et pascal papé et
et et pilar badaboum
patatras une d'un magazine fort célèbre
et qu'est ce qu'on apprend elle n'est
plus avec son fiancé en maïs alors là je
m interroge mais bram et basson ballon
[Rires]
on n'a pas de rigueur parce qu'on n'a
pas les images évidemment mais j'en suis
quand même ballan de cette histoire de
parler une fan de johnny c'est parti
entrez entrez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça va bien
alors on se voit souvent inscrire avec
siri vous êtes un vrai fan de johnny dd
tu as fait et je suppose que ces
derniers jours vous avez été horrifiée
par toutes ces révélations ont été
faites par laetitia déjà patatras genre
la couverture qui est tombé ça lui
ce matin donc c'est la couverture de
closer et on y apprend qu'elle n'est
plus avec son fiancé et là on reste
comme deux ronds de flan
tiens on en reste totalement ballan
champion plus de repères alors kévin
méthionine qui peut dire qui est pas
qu'ils aient paru l'âge envie de dire le
timing comme de par hasard cette
nouvelle en terme de communication je
pense que alors là c'est pour une fois
je vois le mal partout mais je me
demande si c'est pas là ça peut pas être
fait que c'est là que je me suis dit à
bor savin que quand on lit l'article ya
quand même des éléments qui m'a un petit
peu perturbée notamment quand on parle
de pascal donc son ex en l'occurrence où
le pascal était irritable produit des
tensions dans le couple à semer le doute
en gros c'est lui qui a tort sur toute
la ligne comme si il y avait une volonté
de communication autour de laëtitia je
dis ça je dis rien on s'est beaucoup de
célébrités aujourd'hui font appel aux
journaux pipe aux journaux people
on appelle ça des commandes au journal
comme par hasard qu'on tienne campagne
de communication alors
alors là alors moi je suis pas sûr à
votre question à qui profite le crime
franchement sur la couverture papa
laetitia non-match marre de l'image je
parle de l'ensemble du dossier quand on
le lit vraiment de az pourquoi pas fut
pas d'accord avec voir alors alors
pourtant on à béton en elle-même suivie
la promotion de laetitia et dans sept à
huit à l'évoquer son nouvel avion et
jusqu'à ce le moment là bas rien de
balancer
voyez le sujet royal 6 agréable un
nouvel homme dans votre ville vous vous
l'autorisez oui j'ai beaucoup de mal au
départ c'est très difficile d'apprendre
à aimer
c'était très difficile de à l'impression
de tromper son mari on a l'impression
qu'on peut pourra pas aimé qu'on n'en
sera pas capable d'aimer pas nouveau
pour notre homme vous touchent qu'un
autre homme puisse un jeu vous puissiez
ouvrir votre coeur à notre homme sait ça
paraît tellement compliqué c'est
vertigineux et ses seins parce que le
manque que reste abyssal
mais que la comparaison est toujours
assez on a tendance à comparer alors
qu'il faut pas comparer la place de
johnny est encore bien présente et un
c'est pas facile c'est pas facilement
non on est souvent un couple a trois
magali on se connaît un petit peu je
vous dit de rester calme au jeu c'est de
rester poli surtout dans vos propos mais
je suppose quand vous voyez ça est
derrière la couleur de peuples closer ça
vous énerve un petit peu on parle tout
le temps dell mais vous pensez que c'est
quoi ces c'est c'est c'est que de la
communication et bien sûr sans johnny
les quoi elle à l'existant intérêts
présente son nom mais c'est un peu
réducteur
parce que nous on sait que leur fait ça
non parce que on savait qu'il y avait
sûrement des torts et à dd mais
honnêtement je pense qu'elle a une
qualité quand même et un gala à cette
affaire ici à des mois c'est vivre
johnny et ea l'a fait à la fin c'est
beaucoup de choses alors après blé dont
l'héritage est pour les 125 ans bien sûr
que s'ils avouent penser que tout est
calculé depuis le début mais ça arrange
et tout ça rien que le père a déjà il
faut sa fille dans les bras de quelqu'un
qui voyait comme un drogué alcoolique et
compagnie c'est pas bon je suis d'accord
avec vous étonnamment d'accord excusez
moi mais vous voulez vous nous trouvez
aucune qualité
aucune est ce que vous avez
des chiffres du monde vient à passer
bah je sais pas non mais non mais faut
diviser en hausse car elle c'est une
comédienne
ah non mais ah oui c'est vrai que quand
on voit ce est ce que vous l'avez
trouvée crédible par tous là dessus elle
respire l'hypocrisie moi j'ai pas mes du
tout cru à son discours
hélas elle dit bon voilà c'est compliqué
ce qui peut être vrai mais là quelqu'un
refait sa vie à elle rechange
elle a quelques uns à tout faire mais
c'est ça tient pas trop la route tout ça
même si elle est veuve excusez moi et
elle a quand même le droit de regarder
mon frère je dis juste que son discours
il est il un peu trop nier dieu et moi
je trouve que c'est ça respire pas
l'honnêteté moi je le ressens que
l'autre côté lors y est c'est bon un bep
de l'honnêteté
vous n'êtes même pas content qu'ils
aient un nouvel album soul ou à défaut
une belle chanson qui sonne si ces
dernières années bien sûr il le faut
comme ça on oublie pas il est toujours
là là où certaines
personnes peuvent se faire un petit on y
restera le plus grand souvenir de qui je
veux parler et pas du tout celle ci
aussi là il ferait bien de se faire
oublier
ouais mais elle est ce que est ce que
vous avez toujours eu la haine contre
eux
ah oui ça depuis le début alors oui à
vous l'ayez pas du palais d'été pour
naviguer n'est jamais pour benjamin
juste un truc vous reconnaissez quand
même elle est supportée johnny johnny
lui-même disait que la famille bhutto
était bien mais de ploucs
ça en dit long non mais ils voulaient
avoir la paix pour avoir la paix mais il
sortait beaucoup les nuits et remettre
les états un peu second porte et je la
défends pas mais ce que je vous dit
juste c'est que la vie de johnny il ya
encore quelques années il fallait comme
la supporter et la partager donc je
pense qu'elle n'a pas que des torts et
l'asim et ben oui moi je suis une grande
fan de johnny d'idées madame avec tout
le respect que je vous dois je peux pas
vous entendre dire que une femme déjà
n'a pas d'intérêt parce que toutes les
femmes ont de l'intérêt qu'elle quelle
soit d'accord ensuite je trouve que
johnny l'a aimée et on le sait tout
en tant que fan de johnny est rien par
respect pour l'amour qui lui apporter on
doit aussi la respecter ne pas lui
manquer de respect ces moines se fait
harceler et c'est pas c'est pas juste
déjà delà de la excusez moi du terme de
la massacrer comme ça publiquement alors
que déjà elle n'est pas là elle peut pas
se défendre c'est bien dommage
d'ailleurs on aurait bien aimé mais je
trouve que c'est dur les paroles sont
durs les mots sont durs ça reste un être
humain ça reste une femme qui a des
enfants
ça reste une femme qui a eu à coeur
comme dit nicolas elle a supporté son
mari son mari l'a supporté vous avez
raison c'est un couple mais on peut pas
être aussi intrusif dans un couple comme
ça alors que finalement on n'a pas vécu
avec nous avec un ni vous ni moi est-ce
que c'est pas finalement magali le fait
que cet épisode de l'héritage qui nous a
un peu remonté contre détiendra donc là
tant qu'on n'est pas ouvert le testament
a pas se mentir
oui c'est allé très réussi à persuader
angers personne et elle dit dans son
coin quand on n'entendait pas beaucoup
et on disait surtout qu'elle avait
beaucoup de beaucoup d'autres étaient
donc c'est de supporter johnny j'ai
l'impression alors moi je franchement
moi je ne suis pas par on2 dans son clan
vous le savez le côté mais c'est d'être
un peu objectif vivre avec johnny c'est
franchement il faut de beaucoup de
qualités
alors vous allez me dire oui il y avait
d'héritage au bout mais ya vingt ans
elle pensait pas déjà si c'est ici alors
quels sont les principes horrible je
vous le dis ce qu'ils sont
jean-pierre débatte vous c'est vous
c'est comme ça est fini et je suis pas
la salle j'ai un master qui pensent la
même chose alors il ya quand même temps
c'est vrai que tout ça malheureusement
malheureusement ou heureusement je ne
sais pas tout ça a été fait autour de la
promo un dock qui a été tourné on en a
un petit extrait on en parle juste après
et j'arrive najet je vous promets regard
je regarde
on avait des étapes de 500 kilomètres
qui la traversent
physiquement comme 7
au foie le froid moi j'étais comme ça
sur la moto et l'accueil sont là les
points dont six sportifs pour faire des
bornes j'avais l'impression d'avoir
avalé une perceuse en arrivant à l'hôtel
histoire oubliée patel 72,6 des mecs qui
est un dur à cuire que pensez-vous ces
documents à sa magnifique a quand même
oui merci
consciente que le team ont été faits
mais bien sur wii est bien content que
laeticia est permis que le champion soit
publiée et sortent
j'essaie d'y aller comme un village mois
on peut pas d'un côté dire
johnny était une immense et pas un
élément c'était l'un des plus grands
c'est ce n'est le plus grand et tout le
monde aime 2 derrière lui qui n'aime pas
mais bon peu importe mais c'est vrai que
la seule façon et je suis bien placé
pour vous en parler c'est que pour faire
vivre un héritage et c'est un travail on
peut pas on peut pas dire s'est il était
comme s'y est pas le faire vivre
donc ça veut dire sortir des chansons
j'ai été le premier à me moquer un peu
de la chanson qu'ils on se dit bon c'est
de l'humour mais en live on veut que
johnny reste dans les dix quinze vingt
trente années à venir faut quelqu'un
s'occupe de ça alors qu'est ce que c'est
pas la mieux placée pour ça qu'est ce
que vous pouvez dire ça mais mais on
peut pas en vouloir
ça certaines la seule chance de vienne
kafana samedi comment certaines la seule
chance de bien qu'ils étaient bien
servis en fait voilà donc vous devrez la
remercie pour ça j'arrive najet je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les tissus
je ne connais absolument pas mais paye
un peu la facture des grosseurs de
communication du début depuis le début
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu le 20 heures de
tf1 qui était longuement de critiquer
les interviews aujourd'hui qui sont
multipliés ou à chaque fois ce sont les
mêmes réponses aux maux prêts etc
il ya eu lors de l'héritage via les
réseaux sociaux il ya des éléments de
langage qui ont été utilisés aujourd'hui
elles payent la facture ce que madame
aujourd'hui si vous appréciez ce genre
de document c'est grâce à elle aussi
faux de l'admettre faut être de mauvaise
foi également comme les titres qui
sortent aujourd'hui c'est pas si elle
donne aussi son feu vert parce qu'elle
est comme mélodique gardienne de son
héritage on n'a pas le choix et c'est
que l'argent arrive je trouve que je
trouve ça anormal je vous le dis là pour
le coup que soap à david et aussi nos
racines
tu as totalement benjamin il ya une
chose quand même je les ai vus ensemble
à plusieurs reprises j'ai dîné avec eux
souvent je ne suis pas là pour défendre
laetitia j'ai aussi beaucoup de mal à
croire à certaines choses mais
incontestablement elle a eu une ont
durant ce exceptionnelle avec un autre
bien difficile mais surtout elle l'a
aussi structuré et moi ce que je pense
c'est que sans elle
et pourtant j'aime et johnny vous pouvez
pas dire le contraire madame parce qu'on
était très proche depuis très longtemps
mais je pense que sans elle il serait
mort avant et ruiné depuis très
longtemps la raison elle la structure et
comme personne ne l'avait fait avant
rien pour ça un petit peu de respect
après il ya beaucoup de choses très
défavorable sans aucun doute
alors moi je suis un peu mitigé est
d'accord avec monsieur et magali passer
les 60 euros didier vincent des sens où
on ne peut pas juger la vie des gens je
pense que dionis et une femme qu'il a
aimée et on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
dire si elle aimait vraiment ou pas je
pense que moi il ya des choses pour moi
elle en fait beaucoup trop elle devrait
rester plus naturel
après je pense que c'est pas évident
d'être utile et chaussées
on va avancer on va avancer avec là on
va avancer que déclarations qu'elle a
faites dans le parisien où elle dit
l'embargo gare des halles a déclaré je
suis je suis je suis américaine
je suis à la mairie générique and manage
cérémonie officielle a eu lieu en
septembre là encore j'ai respecté ses
volontés je suis allé au bout de la
naturalisation que terra bon alors ça
suppose que ça à faire nous énerve c'est
extra merci magali ça m'énerve quand on
parle de laëtitia j'ai tendance à dire
je m'en fous un peu ni
je suis excité respecte ses volontés
parce qu'on a la preuve par a plus b
vraiment que johnny voulait devenir
américaine il voulait vivre en amérique
dans la vie de johnny 6 1 6 1 elle a
quelque chose qui est présente quand
même depuis depuis la naissance et
l'amérique sur célé lui les métiers de
fans de john wayne et de quoi être
naturalisé année là oui c'est alors je
vais vous dire moi je connais pas très
bien donner je connais un peu mais quand
je parlais cinéma avec lui il me parlait
que du cinéma écrit me tue encore mais
de là à vouloir être naturalisé web
libre oui peut-être
certainement même d'ailleurs mais
naturalisé j'ai un gros doute bassong
globale morose avait un gros doute sur
sa bouche oui c'est oui oui kevin
devient une chose à rajouter ont cédé ma
gueule magali bardou bélanger des
différences liées mois derrière les
barreaux
non mais je trouve qu'on a tendance à
lui jeter la pierre mais effectivement
faut pas oublier que lui il était parti
aussi en suisse après le talent aux
états unis et cetera
moi je vois pas pourquoi tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps attaqué
laetitia trouve très sincère mois dans
son interview quand je vois ce que tu
dis moi je la trouve vraiment sincère on
la tue rachat trouve très naturel est
arrivé naturel pas maquillée elle est
simple elle se montre avec ses filles
elle assume et ses trucs contre est très
courageux de sa part parce qu'elles
continuent à aller dans son chemin et
continue sa ligne directrice du des
directives pardon du début moi je trouve
ça très courageux pour une femme qui
pour moi aujourd'hui est un peu isolé
tous ajustements et m6 elle fait même
limite de la peine de la voir s'en
prendre plein la gueule comme ça on va
pas le dvd parce qu'on a déjà fait que
cyril mais quand tu vous vous enchaînez
des interviews qu'elle a fait à chaque
fois c'est des éléments non gel de
langage et c'est la même chose alors là
pour le coup s'cusez moi ça plus là
comme un plan b
elle est branchée sur wii fait c'est
prouvé qu'elle passe par marseille à
café plusieurs interviews on vous savez
très bien fait dans leur désir interview
souvent reviennent les mêmes questions
donc forcément répondre la même chose a
pas de contredire des interviews winter
family c'est un retour médiatique
réussie ou non les beautés de conquête
pour vous je vous dis pas la pancarte
sur la question est ce que tu as fait un
retour médiatique réussie oui non oui
bah oui bon en fait moi je trouve
qu'avec la coupe qui vient de sortir qui
pour moi n'est pas du tout anodine et
pour moi et la nuit pour quelque chose
comme il s'en est pris plein la tête
après sept à huit et interview qu'elle a
donnée
je trouve que c'est bien pratique pour
elle que ça sorte maintenant qu'un vater
est triste et malheureuse et tout ça et
peut-être apporter un peu d'empathie sfi
d'accord excusez moi mais là c'est la
couverture elle sort maintenant parce
qu'elle vient de rompre maintenant je
suis désolé faut pas qu'elle a jamais
rien pour mieux vu lille le sujet tu
vois je lis les les lucquois excuse moi
je trouverai les éléments
[Rires]
écoutons kevin des informations non mais
ce que je disais c'est que encore une
fois c'est parce qu'à des tirs et a
produit des tensions de la bla bla sait
jamais c'est pas de sa faute du tout
mais je suis désolé vous devriez magali
être être ravis qu'elle est pourquoi
elle a rompu pourquoi est-ce que voilà
mais c est la revue parce qu'elle a un
autre côté elle a rompu parce que déjà
ça c'est un vrai lac aucun amy pascal ne
supportait pas qu'elle qui viennent
espèce de mausolées atelier à l'idée il
n'a pas voulu aller se recueillir sur la
tombe avec elle c'est là que ça a
commencé à mal aller et elle lui a
annoncé
là il ya quelques jours dans un
restaurant voilà nous nous pensons avec
la saga call à quelqu'un si c'est à dire
ce qu'on veut on vend nos grands noms
qui ont parlé longtemps que je serai
bien quand même que les enfants sont un
peu concernés pour l'ast de la promo
effectivement et qui est un drogué
râpeux partagé parce que pour le coup ça
pourra finir par lasser
non